[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at our respective
tables of our individual homes yes we're
still at home I got to stop saying yes
we're still at home hey we're still at
home like it's a good thing we are
discussing the topic I taught me that we
briefly touched on many times while
discussing other things but we've never
devoted an entire episode to unpacking
this topic and it's the business side of
things
how did mythical entertainment develop
as a company yes and you know when we
started doing all this we didn't have a
business in mind it wasn't like we're
starting a business it was we're just
we're gonna create things but slowly
over the years it's gone from two guys
making things on YouTube to two guys
leading a team of over 80 people and
it's just definitely a business at this
point even though it was never our
intention it would never thought
ourselves a CEO so we're gonna kind of
unpack that process and touch on some
things that we've talked about briefly
but get into some new things but mainly
we want to focus on the lessons that we
have learned along the way yeah and if
you're particularly interested in
business then maybe you own a company of
your own or you aspire to one day maybe
you can learn a thing or two as we share
the things that we've learned or if
you're really not into that we think
there's still you'd be interested in
finding out the path that we took and I
think there's applications outside of
business as well so thanks for coming
along for the ride no matter what your
interests are yeah I mean the truth is
you know we never thought of ourselves
as CEOs or we never said we want to be
CEOs like you said but it we need when
you talked about that it did remind me
of when the fine brothers made that
video where kids react to rhett and Link
and they one kid described you as the
businessman and described me as the boy
so we became so those are now our
official titles the boy
the official titles like when you look
at like a legal document that I have to
sign it says Rhett mcLaughlin the
businessman and when it's in Charles
link and Neal the third the boy I mean I
don't I mean and that makes me think you
know when we sign things technically I'm
president and you have me to thank for
that and you're what you're not you know
you know what I don't even know nice
president vice present you know why you
have my wife to think for that because I
was having a conversation with our very
first lawyer yeah and he was like you
know I and that was the point in which I
basically I think maybe because my dad
was a law professor I just handled all
the business interactions like I wrote
the agreements and and I was like you
weren't there and he was like okay so
just for legal purposes one of you needs
to be president and one of you needs to
be vice president and he was like so
just think about that and I was like
okay and so then I'm just kind of
telling Jesse about the meeting or
whatever and like so one of us is gonna
be president one of us gonna be vice
president it doesn't mean anything
we have it's gonna be but it's weird
because I think she he was like that's
all more complicated he's not worth it
yeah and we're like 50/50 owners we have
a 50/50 interest and we have Fitz always
50/50 and Jesse was like well since
you're the one making the decision you
should make link president because it
would sort of a be you know a butthole
move to be the one making the decision
and to make yourself president so now
there's a press less of my little
entertainment it defer the lesson that I
learned I'm actually the vice president
and secretary you don't want to be the
president all it means is that I have to
sign more blanks than you on things that
we still both have to sign because that
was when we created our first business
entity was called rhettandlink creations
where the K at the
end of link became the beginning of the
word creations if you misspelled it with
a k' and another lesson learned
oh we're full of them is that if you
name your business something people
can't understand how to immediately
spell you're gonna be frustrated a lot
it's like it rhett and Link is one word
and creations as part of it but the K is
shared and I know that's not how you
spell creations and I mean we've changed
the name of our company to mythical
entertainment is it just mythical now
it's still technically mythical
entertainment business name is still
mythical yeah yeah and we kept me as the
president so I still got to fill in a
few more blanks than you but yeah it's
it's just it's just politics actually it
was a real smart move on my part because
I don't like signing things okay but the
worst real lesson that we learned beyond
those that I think is sort of was the
operating principle that got us off the
ground as a business is we had to find
the intersection or the nexus if you
want to use a word like that of our
ability and our opportunity yeah I mean
we we don't need to rehash how we got
from point A to point B to Point C from
being engineers to then working for crew
and then working hosting a television
show called online nation we shared all
of that in episode 1 of our lost year's
series so you can go back and watch that
if you want to know how to how we got
from point A to point B to Point C but
if point C is we were hosting this show
online nation and it got cancelled we
were flying out to LA to shoot it and
then we find ourselves back in our
little basement where we were making
videos back at square one making videos
again but we had no no income anymore we
just had the money that we made off of
that show and we were living off of that
while we figured out what it was we were
going to do we had to develop an
entirely new business plan and there was
no it's important to note no one was
making money on YouTube directly there
was no YouTube Partner Program so you
couldn't just make a video and then see
money rolling
so really there was no such thing as a
professional youtuber so it's a really
interesting idea that we were like we're
going to have a career because we were
like let's make this YouTube thing a
full-time thing but yet no one was
making it a career but again we were
like what two things exists here we know
that we can write a funny song we can
make a funny music video we had had
success with that the Facebook song had
gone really big and the second piece of
the puzzle was is we knew that there
were businesses out there who wanted
people to know about them so it was like
okay can we put those two things
together can we put our ability to write
a funny song with a company that wants
to advertise and put that on YouTube and
it was really just an open question at
the time and there weren't a lot of big
companies that were sponsoring videos I
think there was some of that it's not
like we came up with the idea out of
absolutely nothing out of thin air but
they're definitely warm they're
definitely weren't big companies
investing a lot of money in this
platform where no one understood YouTube
or digital video that well but it it
seemed like our best play because the
thing that we wanted to make is the
thing that we could also sell or at
least sell ad space in and we thought we
could do a good job of making it an
integration so that it made sense that
the ad was was a part of it it wasn't
like a lot of videos today where you
could you know you would be vlogging or
doing whatever you're doing in your
video and then you could just insert an
ad in the middle and people would
understand that and here's the coupon
code and here's you know here's what
here's who my sponsor is kind of thing
so we wanted to do something that was
that was thoughtful that we could be
proud of but also make money and feed
our kids
because we already had kids at the time
that if you want it if you want to
really be driven to succeed at business
have children have children first you
have children first that's what because
they tend to be hungry and demanding and
you come home to them and you're like
man I gotta get after it well it's it's
one thing to be a starving artist it's
one thing to have a starving family so
it went when you when you put other
people are selling you're responsible
for them you know that's definitely a
great motivator so what we did is we
wrote the cornhole song about the
classic game beanbag toss game that was
really popular in the Midwest at the
time singing in 2024 so and we cold
called we would literally look up people
who were selling corn haul equipment and
we we would just find the number or the
contact email because they were internet
call them it made sense okay they
probably never understand that well we
knew it because they're in there oh
they're an internet based business we
weren't gonna call like coke right and
say hey we've got an idea we knew that
there was no way for us to go to a
fortune 500 company and get our foot in
the door but maybe we can find somebody
else who was trying to do what we were
doing and after a few different phone
calls that didn't lead somewhere we had
talked to a mom who was selling cornhole
equipment out of her garage and she was
like I love the idea but I just can't I
can't afford any advertising we finally
connected with the guys at ajj cornhole
who were about our age it was three of
them they were starting their business
in Ohio they were exactly at the same
place as we were and they were trying to
just get it off the ground and do
something interesting and they loved the
idea and they became the sponsor again
at the time I wrote the contract up just
based on some guesswork as how much do
you get paid to do this I don't know you
get some initial fee and then you get
some money based on how well it performs
that makes sense to us that was like
they paid us
a few thousand dollars and then we can
we knew that we knew that CPMs were a
thing we knew that there was a way to
get paid based on performance because of
revver the that website at the time was
actually paying people for their videos
and their performance which no one was
watching our videos over there but we
knew that there was the concept of this
cost per million views or whatever
getting getting some getting some money
back yes we did that we we wrote a song
about how iPods die called the dead iPod
song we asked our friend iJustine to
collaborate in the video so we could get
more views I think we even shared I
don't know if we shared some of the
integration fee with her or if she just
did it as a favor but it wasn't that
much either let's say we did I rescued
calm repairs iPods so that was perfect
yeah they got us off the ground they
were the only ones besides ourselves who
believed in us but then from there we we
got a call to be a part of an
alka-seltzer campaign which was a
bonafide transition that was that was a
transition from us having to go out and
find these people ourselves to doing it
the way that we've done it ever since
which is fielding the opportunities
usually either directly from a business
or through an agency and that one in
2008 21 videos for the alka-seltzer
great American road trip where we went
along the we were you know took an RV
the trip across the United States and
made 21 videos that were food themed and
that was the beginning of us kind of
understanding like oh okay
once you get your work out there and
people see that you're incorporating
companies into it maybe the people will
come to us with the integrations and
that's what happened and we basically
have never looked back I think that next
that is a look you're talking about was
that we were able to do in a way that
wasn't cringy and we were communicating
with our audience at the time we were
telling the mythical beast hey
we wouldn't be able to to make this
level of content with this type of
production value if we didn't have the
sponsor so go support them and it was we
were very grateful for the sponsors and
we conveyed that to the audience and I
think that you know I that it was it was
in no way cringy it worked for everybody
and so it yeah it led to more
opportunities once you start working
with agencies that thing starts
happening when we started making I mean
commercial Kings wouldn't exist if it
wasn't first for a sponsor micro built
you know the CEO was a fan he started
communicating with us he sponsored one
little video went well so then we
hatched the idea to start making
intentionally bad local commercials for
his customer base who were small
businesses yeah and who knew that a few
weeks later we would be interviewed on
CNN and then you know talking about
selling furniture yeah
the vice president of rattling creations
on the line so that led that led to
everything that led to commercial Kings
that led to us moving to California so
again I think that if you're out there
listening to this mandi want your
particular skill to be translated into a
business opportunity I do think that and
this is not a simple question it's a
simple thing to ask yourself it's not a
simple thing to do but just do you have
something that people that you can do
that you're uniquely good at that people
are willing to pay for
I sound almost too simplistic but we had
we had to start there because we didn't
have a choice except to like go back and
try to use our engineering degrees again
which wasn't something that we were
interested in doing we got some other
lessons but first just want to give a
quick plug two mythical calm we got lots
of grooming stuff over there you can
groom your lips with lip balm is that
considered grooming all right
technically but I want to acknowledge
that I may not look like the kind of
person who should represent grooming as
a concept I may seem not well groomed
that does not mean that our grooming
products are not top-of-the-line
we got palmate we got beard oil we got
lip balm and they're all incredibly
high-quality they smell good and they
make you smell good they work
effectively try it out they're all
available at mythical calm gifted repure
boys all right let's get into the next
lesson I think one of the ways that we
tended to approach everything and maybe
this was born out of desperation a
little bit was we were always looking
for another opportunity that we could
seize once people started coming to us
and asking us to do things it was not
that we said yes to everything but that
we had this belief that not doing
something won't lead to anything it's
well it's doing things that we'll need
to think I would be more specific and
say that we didn't at the time we didn't
know that we've learned that lesson
looking back I don't think we understood
that at the time because typically with
a couple of examples that we'll talk
about we started to do things with some
kind of intention right we thought that
something might come from them and it
was very rarely the thing that we
intended initially that was the result
it was almost always just the decision
to do something that then led to the
thing that we actually ended up doing
sure I mean we didn't know that taking
the sponsorship to make local
commercials would lead to us having a
television show on IFC and moving to Los
Angeles but we never would have realized
that if we didn't give everything we got
to to those commercials some of which
you know a few of them sucked but a few
of them really popped and it made all
the difference in the world good I think
the good morning tea Lincoln is another
great example right so good morning she
Lincoln 2011 we made the decision to
start what was a daily show the two of
us sitting at a card table talking about
whatever we had been talking about when
we came into work we made the decision
to do that
simply because we had already decided
that we were gonna go and shoot
commercial Kings and we thought well
this might be this opportunity to make a
television show and we're gonna move to
California a lot of things were up in
the air but we knew that was a very real
possibility we didn't know what that was
gonna mean for YouTube but one of the
things that had been happening over the
past couple of years on YouTube that we
had never participated in at all was a
regular daily video people were doing
daily vlogs at the time and their
audiences and their views were
increasing exponentially because it
seemed like people wanted a daily point
of contact now we knew we didn't want to
make daily vlogs or family vlogs at the
time right but we were like what can we
do every single day and the answer was
good morning Sheila Lincoln but we said
from the beginning that it would end
only as long as a Chia Lincoln would
stay alive which is about 40 days
apparently which is how long the show
lasted because we knew we'd be working
on the pilot to commercial Kings and
also we didn't we don't want people to
get attached to it if it wasn't
something that we were going to continue
forever so we just kind of put an end
date at the beginning knowing that if we
wanted to continue it we could of course
we didn't continue it until after
commercial Kings wasn't reordered for a
second season we found ourselves living
in Los Angeles feeling like we were back
at square one again trying to develop
our a new business strategy and that was
going back to sponsorships and getting
that rolling again with music videos but
then also developing contact with the
mythical beasts and reinstituting good
morning T Lincoln as good mythical
morning again not knowing what it would
lead to except that it would it would
span the gaps in between our high
production music videos that where we
were actually making money well one
thing I think we did know we had begun
to learn that lesson a little bit having
done good morning Sheila Lincoln and we
knew that people responded to it and we
knew that we were good at it we knew
that we could sit down and we could talk
about something
minutes right yeah kind of discovered it
by trying it so when you watch that
first episode of good mythical morning I
actually saw somebody tweet just this
little slice of the video the very
beginning of the video we had this we're
talking about good mythical morning in
this aspirational way and we're saying
yeah you know we hope that this is the
beginning of something special something
that you will make a part of your daily
routine and I think the reason that we
were saying that is because we actually
believed it based on this previous
experience the hey all right our
audience has connected with this and now
we're kind of formalizing it and saying
that we're making an indefinite
commitment to doing this show for
however long and we're still doing it
and it was based on that having just
made the decision to good to do good
morning she Lincoln but there's the but
the sort of a huge piece that's a part
of this story is you know we started
doing GMM but then after doing a couple
of seasons of GMM YouTube came to us
with the creative Innovation Program
where they were basically giving people
money to make things and we had a pretty
good relationship with YouTube at the
time they said hey do you guys have any
ideas and we reacted to that by saying
yeah we got an idea to do a variety show
called the mythical show it's a half
hour long show featuring sketch and
music videos and weird games and stuff
like that taking everything that we had
done thus far on YouTube and combining
it into one product and at that point we
of course needed help to make the show
so we that was when we hired Stevie who
didn't hire some other people to them
build the team out for because we had a
budget all of a sudden we were given a
chunk of money for the first time up
front to make we were commissioned to
make a show and not just to make an
integration with a sponsor YouTube was
investing in order to learn to see what
they could learn from longer form
content on on the platform so we hire
Stevie just to make those 10 episodes
and we also hired her in 12 and then to
build out the team so she immediately
turned around and hired Ben who's still
working for us and he's starting to
build out the team from there
well I specifically remember 12 because
just this may be of interest to you if
you're in the video world but I remember
me and you sat down because they were
like well come up with a budget like how
much money do you need and we sat down
and we like budgeted everything out now
we have been making videos for nothing
right so we budgeted everything out and
then we added like a 20% buffer and we
still landed at $100,000 total which may
sound like a lot of money half-hour
episodes but that's nothing twelve it's
not foul
it's not a lot of money as we discovered
very quickly for a half-hour of what is
essentially television which at least in
the first episode had a studio audience
so yeah we've quickly took the studio
audience out we didn't kill them but we
took them out because they no one liked
it
we could've probably benefited from some
some advice around pricing of that type
of thing because we should have
suspected someone yeah like I mean
Stevie is a producer we didn't bring her
on until the until we had negotiated
yeah we didn't we didn't we came up with
a budget oh you know what YouTube was
thinking when we said a hundred thousand
dollars they were like we could have
said 500 thousand dollars and they would
have probably still thought it was a
deal I we just we just didn't know okay
but we thought just if you go back you
can still find the mythical show there's
still our hardcore fans still like the
show and see it as sort of a oh sweet
awesome time and I know you're like me
but the reality is is that we thought
that we had come up with something that
wasn't just a good product we thought
that we had come up with something that
was going to change the landscape of
YouTube in fact the tagline of the show
was your half-hour of not having to
click around on the internet we thought
we were going to change the habits of
people on YouTube and at the time in
2012 people
making three minute videos if you went
above three minutes it was like uh this
is kind of weird I don't know if I can
hang on now nowadays people will make 20
minute videos and everybody watches them
but at the time everybody was doing
these short videos so we were going
against the grain we thought we were
gonna change the way people behaved but
it didn't happen no one really cared
about the show beyond our immediate fan
base but again it's the only reason that
we started growing from that point on
because we had to hire Stevie who then
had to hire a team and that was really
the beginning of the totally new phase
of business which was when we began to
delegate responsibilities and have a
team yeah I think that's the big lesson
that we had to start learning what was
we had to learn to trust others with our
vision and you know with Stevie with Ben
with hiring you know we hired Jen to
start helping tweet for us and do social
media it's like oh we can't do
everything anymore we started building
the team from their trust was
incremental right I mean Stevie was
gonna do those twelve episodes but then
we started to discover that hey we
worked well together she brings a lot of
strengths she thinks through things in a
way that we don't and she executes
things too in a way that we couldn't and
it frees us up in a way that we only
dreamed about
or we didn't even give ourselves
permission to dream about that was not
an easy thing nothing that and as we've
talked to creators over the years
especially when we back on this podcast
on your business when we used to
interview other creators what we learned
is that this is the common challenge for
every creator which is trusting somebody
else if you something is really trusting
somebody with an edit if you're probably
doing it you're gonna always be doing it
it's you never learn to stop you never
learned that someone else can do it
unless you give someone else a shot at
doing it and you may have to go three WP
we didn't know that we didn't know that
what I'm saying is I think the mythical
show was the beginning of that lesson
learned because yeah for a mythical
mythical show we were over the shoulder
of the editor we were making very
specific decisions about the Edit we put
our heart and soul into that but then by
the time we got to the end of that
almost by necessity we were like this is
too much content like we can't do
everything we can't be responsible for
everything and by the way everything
that stevie has come in and contributed
to and sort of overseen she's done an
incredible job so then once the mythical
show was over and we made the transition
back into good mythical morning it was
easy for us at that point is say you
know what I don't think we're going to
actually watch the edit I don't think
because this is a daily show I mean this
is gonna be a big part of your day if
you're gonna be responsible for making
the show and then sitting down and
helping to put together they edit and
improve the Edit he's at that point
after the mythical show we set that
aside and again we saw the show
continued to grow and to get better and
to grow audience without having to be
super involved in every single aspect
Jason who was working for us through the
mythical show and then when we restarted
good mythical morning we were he was
like I said we were over his shoulder
like you said as he was editing and so
that was an incremental level of trust
that then was Steve who able to build on
that and you add more people to the team
and you start to realize that people can
do things better than we can and slowly
you move to a point where you start to
we were able to start to focus on the
things that we wanted to do and the
things that we wanted to bite off and
and try to figure out and it it drove us
to trust people even more because we had
we've started to learn that lesson and I
think that in in some ways what we're
constantly learning and applying that
lesson of what what else do we want to
be doing with our time that we will be
the best at what else are we doing right
now that we can ask someone else to do
and give them an opportunity to do it
better too
to delegate so well we've asked her we
asked ourselves that question and I
would say one of the biggest exercises
the most important exercises that we do
every year we do it multiple times a
year but there's a time every single
year where we kind of sit down and we
look at everything that we've done we
look back at our schedule and we think
what did we do this year that we don't
have to do this year what do we do last
year that we don't have to do this year
so it's like a trust if I'm sitting
there and I'm like why am i sketching
out a concept for a t-shirt when I'm
that's not what I really want to be
doing right now I can get excited I'm
not good at it and we're not yeah we're
not we're not we're definitely on as
good at it as Caleb who's working for us
now and Feldman who's working with him
and that entire team with Dana and then
hey you got this team you need someone
to start to manage this team so you
bring in somebody like Raz and you start
to build a team of people who can give
focus and they can also pour their
passion into it in a way that we were
just trying to get it done and if we
pour too much passion into it it would
be it would be the wrong type of
investment so what was the transition
from it's the transition from getting
people to do exactly what you want them
to do to getting them to inspiring them
to do what they can actually do better
and that they want to do and that's been
a slow incremental process but now using
merch as an example we see the t-shirt
designs when you see the t-shirt designs
we see them when they're in the store
most of the time and in multiple things
it's like you know I've got the three
different good mythical morning mugs
right here and again these were on the
desk and I know you tend to be want to
be you have to it's different more
difficult for you to take yourself out
of the details but for me the first time
I saw these mugs was when they were on
our desk on the show yeah and I saw him
once but and I gave a limited amount of
notes but it
that that was a level of discipline that
I've learned and I've also learned to
try to trust them that they can design
something is gonna connect with mythical
beasts even better than I can and that's
that's just something I had to I had to
change my mind about you know and I
think is it may seem weird to say that
it's like well people are attracted to
to what we're creating but we just try
to be it's what our I'm proud of what we
as a team create and I also trust them
to come up with the stuff that's going
to connect and they prove themselves
again and again and that doesn't mean
we're not involved I know you wanna
because I like you said because there is
it there is a balance here so the thing
is is that again still using this whole
merchandise thing and really you can use
anything as an example because we're not
making films we're making Internet
content so even if we see something and
it gets out there on the Internet and
then we are like I don't like the way
that looks or I don't like the general
direction that this is going that's
actually where we get involved because
we are watching a lot of stuff that
we're doing we're analyzing people's
reactions to it and so when we think
that there needs to be a shift in a
certain direction in any one of these
departments we do get involved at that
point knowing that hey this is you can
you can kind of course correct it's not
that big of a deal so it's not like
we're completely hands-off but the
development and the execution of those
things on sort of a very my new level is
something that we have necessarily
removed ourselves from and we're sort of
just managing it from a higher vantage
point I think you're also touching on
the fact that we're not just developing
let's say a t-shirt design we're
developing a t-shirt designer who it can
then embody mythicality from scratch and
can Caleb can express himself and have
fun collaborating with his team and with
his team leader and present something to
us that is surprising and that connects
but also sometimes doesn't
and then that's a lesson you just can't
you can't tell somebody something in
them learn something you've got to
experience that you know you learn that
as parents and some at some point the
kids got a jump out of the nest I have a
nest in the backyard I mean my kids jump
out of it it's kind of a burden I
thought you talked about your Birds I
thought you're talking about your family
of birds that you've been raising no
it's my family of humans I've make them
to learn how to jump out of the
metaphorical nest I push them out of a
physical nest that I've built in the
backyard that sounds like a good that
sounds like a product that we could that
we could sell think about biblical
kitchen you know I think that's that's
another very current example of that
team developing content within certain
parameters and vision that we've helped
set up that in order for a mythical
kitchen to really develop a life of its
own it needs to be an expression of Josh
and that team working together to
passionately put stuff out into the
world to recreate the experience that
we've had and we continue to have on the
content that know that we're directly
working on you know if we just get not
only not only do they know not only do
they know the kind of content that would
work from from a culinary entertainment
standpoint better than we do because
that's what Josh sort of lives and
breathes they're also better at
executing it right I think that that our
role in that was just knowing that we
wanted to develop our culinary team to
the place where you know they're not
just making food for good mythical
morning but they are also this is an
opportunity to create content that a
whole new fan or also existing fans
could connect with because people like
this kind of you know food base content
and then sort of helping to empower Josh
to see his potential as somebody who
could have his own audience like that
was pretty much the vision that the sort
of nebulous vision that we had but then
the specific execution of what is going
to be
on the channel and what are the nature
of the videos going to be that's the
mythical kitchen team you know with the
help of Stevie kind of leading things
creatively and then kind of working
together as a creative team like that is
something that we're just sort of
shepherding loosely mm-hmm it's a better
product because of that because as soon
as I mean do you have you spent a bunch
of time watching recipe videos on the
Internet no have I know maybe more than
you have but not not enough right it's
not like I'm an expert on that but now
we can kind of see what the content is
and we can kind of you know offer some
feedback but again that we don't have
the time or the ability it wouldn't
happen if we insisted on being the ones
who were involved it would never happen
and if it did happen it won't be as good
as it is right now I think another shift
that we've made just to move to a new
lesson learned is shifting from being
solely reactive just to being proactive
you know it's I guess it's not saying
much to say if you're if you're running
a company you you should have a plan and
you should think into the future you
know it's been it's been extremely
difficult when as you're walking on this
sidewalk of internat Ament it's you can
see it forming right beneath your toes
you know there's not a lot of people
that have gone before us that we can
emulate so it's it's it has been
difficult to take a long-term approach
or to have that proactive stance when
it's like I don't know what the next
opportunity is and we just need to say
yes because saying no leads to nothing
you know it's like well at a certain
point we got it we got to think more
forward yeah and as difficult as it is
to develop a three-year or five-year
plan we are getting better at sort of
laying out our long term vision
knowing that it's got to be flexible
given the environment that we're in but
I think an example of this this sort of
crystallizes it down is the way that we
have grown in terms of the physical
space that we're in yes
team right so going from of course we
had the basement and in the studio and
Fuquay but moving out to California
where all of a sudden the mortgage on my
home was or the the rent on my home was
five times what the mortgage on my home
in North Carolina was or six times
things were suddenly very different and
it wasn't like oh I can pay this rent
and also we can have a studio like no we
weren't making enough money for that so
we thankfully had a garage that we were
in at the time and of course it was the
two of us and Jason in there and then
even the first meeting that we had with
Stevie or the first her first day of
work she was in there with us and we
were very quickly realizing this is not
gonna cut it we got to have a space but
we were so conservative in in the way
that we sort of estimated what we're
gonna have to pay and we were kind of
operating I would say kind of fear-based
it was practical but it was a little bit
like don't bite off more than you can
chew so do you remember that first time
that we went out and looked at different
spaces in Burbank before we found this
the the first spot well I specifically
remember like looking at that place I
don't know I don't know what Street it's
on but it's like a storefront like it
has like a glass front it looks like a
hair salon and it's on a major
thoroughfare that people could just walk
in which incidentally is what we had in
Fuquay but a few quotes not Los Angeles
and I remember seriously considering
that and of course what we ended up
going with was a very nondescript place
that no one would ever even though if
people did knock on the door every once
in a while I don't even know what that
place was but downstairs is where we had
a room to build a set for good mythical
morning set is a very loose yeah loose
term there yeah it was a dedicated place
where we could go downstairs and film
episodes of the show and then we could
go back upstairs and just work at our
desks it's not like we had to turn the
camera in an hour it's not like we had
to set up the camera so that our desks
were in the background I mean this was
definitely a step up and we got to a
place with it a few
years of being in that spot where you
know everyone was working pretty much on
top of one another we didn't we had to
not literally stacked desks on top of
each other but that was the only logical
place to go next and so we were like
okay let's let's look for a new space
and I do you remember the place that we
were very close to renting
yeah the guitarist for the doors like
the Jim Morrison band The Doors was
renting a storefront we never met him
but the agent showed us around and in
the back it was just like a cement slab
and it was on air conditioned but we
were like well we can build two sets
back here I mean it's on air
conditioning so it's gonna get to like
110 degrees it was very it was very
Warehouse II it had a giant of giant
beam that kind of went through there was
a giant beam that went through it
remember there was this conversation
about what we could do with that giant
beam because it was gonna be in all the
shots it was it was just storage they
were they were shipping stuff they had
shelving it it would have been horrible
it it would have been a downgrade but we
were seriously considering it but but we
were no we weren't just seriously
considering it we got down to the place
where we said if this guy's willing to
do this if the landlord is willing to do
this one alteration then we'll rent it
in the meantime where we were waiting on
an answer back for that we went to the
studio that we're currently in and now
this was a legitimate studio it had a
real set with soundproofing television
shows have been shot on this set it had
a recording studio it had all these
things that we needed and wanted but we
were looking at it not if we weren't
really looking at it to consider it we
were looking at it because you know our
realtor was like okay here's another
spot this is way out of your price range
but you should look at it just didn't
see that what's available and I remember
walking around our space and thinking
man this is awesome but I can't imagine
I can't imagine
this place up with people I can't
imagine getting to a play how could we
ever get to a place where we would have
enough people to work in this place and
then I I think me and you were on the
same page which was we can't afford this
and it's too big and then Ben she was
working for us at the time I remember he
he kind of pulled us aside and he was
like guys I know that the place that we
looked at because everybody we all went
together to look at the places because
it was our very small team I know that
the place that we looked at yesterday is
kind of like the Ferrari of studios at
least in our minds and I know that it
seems like it might be too much but I
just want to say that I can't remember
his exact words but it was essentially I
know that we could use it and I believe
that we could do great things there and
I just wanna almost from a technical
perspective as your cinematographer you
know the guy who makes things look a
certain way I just want to let you know
that the this would be the real deal and
it made it up yeah we in it and he was
right you know we we ended up when the
when the other side of the building came
up for for lease we had a different
mentality we were like okay it's a win
will there be an opportunity to rent the
contiguous space and double double our
capacity it will not happen again if
somebody else scoops this up so it was
like it really did that really worked
out and we didn't have an idea at the
again we didn't by that time like you
said our mentality had changed we we got
into the space we used it we kind of
quickly got to capacity there because
that seems to be what always happens and
then when that space next door became
available we didn't have any plans for
expansion we didn't have any specific
ideas to fill it right but we did it we
did it was one of the first things that
we've done that was sort of a bigger
risk that was very proactive and it
wasn't waiting for somebody to come
along with an idea or an opportunity
that we can then execute in that space
it was very much let's get the space and
let's expect the opportunity and lo and
behold right after we started renting it
like literally months after we made the
decision to rent it
YouTube came along and said hey we want
to fund a bigger version of GMM and that
was when all of a sudden we had to hire
like 50 people and we had to put them
somewhere and lo of all we had this
space next door yeah and you know just
to move on to the to the next lesson
it's interesting how our culture evolved
and how our understanding of what it
meant to be leaders in a growing company
and how you know how to tackle the
challenges of actually providing
leadership and how to to to to give to
give our vision to our employees and
then empower them so that so that and
then just shape a culture where we could
continue to work together and achieve
our goals and also the ideas that they
could come up with there was a there was
a lot of adjustments in there that we
really started to come to grips with we
are running a business here and I think
a lot of things imposes the lesson very
specifically is that we learned that we
had a culture yeah that that wasn't
something that we had ever thought about
we had been two guys who were executing
a vision trying to create things and
hiring people to contribute directly to
that and empowering them and delegating
but it wasn't until we got to about 20
people when it started to really hit us
I mean I remember we were still doing
things like we're still doing the books
ourselves and just we didn't it was it
was like we were unwilling to admit that
we had a business that we had us it was
a small business but we had a small
business and that we had intentionally
or otherwise we had established a
certain culture and people could kind of
read it but it wasn't something that we
were doing on purpose it was something
that was just kind of happening based on
our personality yeah and I think when we
hired Brian I mean a very strategic hire
for us as our
chief operating officer and head of
business development he was able to
bring a perspective into the all of the
conversations that we would have in
terms of opportunities to to start to
understand and reshape our culture
because I did you know we had this
family atmosphere when you know you
would just hire people and they would be
just as much friends as they would be
employees and like you said when you get
to that about 20 people you start I mean
we personally don't know it what every
person is working on and you know from
day to day it we're zoomed out from that
right and we started to become
interested in instituting another level
of accountability where it's not just
hey if we hire you you remember the
family no matter what you can you
basically accountability was lacks and
there wasn't specific goals in mind so
there was a shift that Brian really
helped us lock into from moving from a
family culture to a team culture
yeah and that can sound I just wanted to
acknowledge if you're you know that may
sound
oh that sounds a little bit harsh I mean
it's not a family anymore but I think
that this is a this was a helpful way
for me to understand it because I was
initially sort of resistant to the idea
because we're nice guys right and we
like being actually pretty conflict
avoidant and we're very loyal and and I
think that those can be good to a
certain degree but what we were finding
is that if you think about a family like
okay here in my family especially as
we're sort of isolated here it's like
everybody's kind of expected to do
things and like you know the kids have
their days where they're supposed to
clean their rooms or you know unload the
dishwasher and they don't always do that
right does that mean and if even if one
of my kids decided that they were gonna
refuse to ever do their part would they
no longer be my son no they're still
gonna live here and we'll get through it
there's still a part of the family
but if you run a business like that you
run into some pretty obvious problems
right
but for if you shift to a team mentality
it's like okay when you think about an
athletic team it's like okay the people
who are on the team are the ones who
believe in the vision are team players
but also can execute and do things well
it's like you get to be a part of the
starting five if you're one of the best
players and you get to be actually on
the team if you're a contributing player
and if you can't contributor if you just
refuse you there's no birthright to
being a part of the team it means that
we might have a difficult conversation
and we might have the ultimate difficult
conversations which is to say we're
gonna have to part ways yeah and I think
we've learned that there's a there is
such a thing as a cultural fit that not
every single person that we think will
work will work that you know and just as
often that person would be the one to
discover you know what I'm actually
interested in and what I'm most gifted
at and where I want to invest my passion
is not in alignment or it doesn't it's
not I'm not a puzzle piece that fits
here because he started to discover that
we started to set expectations so when
we would when we would bring someone new
on to the team we'd say okay our policy
is there's this basically a six-week
trial at the six week mark we're gonna
have an assessment and it's gonna be a
conversation both ways just to know if
this is gonna work or not because you
just can't hire somebody even in the
most diligent way and know if it's gonna
work out that's just it's not reasonable
but I think that we were bringing this
mentality that hey if you're if you're
here you're here for life and it was
just and we got that feedback from from
some people that we brought on on like a
contract basis just to work or that's
how they wanted to work you know
especially in this town so we learn from
that and I think we started a benefit
from that expectation that six weeks in
we're gonna we're gonna have this come
this assessment to see if this is if
this is
good fit for everyone and I said well
another piece of that is this idea of
very direct candid communication yeah
which was not and continues to be a
difficult thing for us to do just
naturally because we're not those kinds
of bosses
but it's an important thing again if
you're if you're the coach of a team and
you're watching your player do something
or you're watching the tape back you
want to be like hey come here
check it take a look at this you see
what you did there I'd rather you do
this that's not the way you communicate
with your family because if you do if
you try to and I'm guilty of this
sometimes and I'm sure you are as well
sometimes I'll go into business leader
mode in my family and trying to get my
kids to do things and it doesn't work in
a family atmosphere where everybody
knows that they're gonna be here forever
but on the team atmosphere it's like hey
listen no this is actually your
compensation and your longevity at this
company are kind of are based on your
contribution to the to the bottom line
in a lot of ways and so we're gonna have
to have some difficult conversations
from time to time and what the more that
that can become just an expectation
mm-hmm and a part of your culture the
healthier everything's gonna be yeah
that easy to get there I think we got
into problems when we wouldn't we we
wouldn't think someone was a good fit or
they wouldn't be their performance
wouldn't it just consistently wouldn't
meet our our standards or our goals then
it was hard to have those conversations
but when we didn't have them and we
skirted the issue it made everything
worse and then we're talking about
parting ways and somebody feels
blindsided and it's you know sometimes
you have to learn lessons we had to
learn some lessons in a more painful way
and it's not you know it's there's a
right way to talk about it but not
talking about it is is his bad news I
think another thing that we had to come
to grips was was we weren't just we
couldn't just lead by osmosis of
you know what our demeanor was and the
fact that we would show up as performers
because we were it people would interact
with us when we were performing you know
shooting good mythical morning and other
things but but there was also an
interaction that we needed to have as
leaders and being visible as our company
grew especially to 80 people of okay
they are they are providing leadership I
understand what this company is
ultimately interested in and made up to
be and what is the culture and what's
the vibe and what what do we what what
is the company care about because what a
rhettandlink care about and do they care
about me all of those things led to
making practical decisions like having a
company-wide meeting every month that
for month after month we would have to
convince ourselves that we needed to
keep having it because we had to realize
there was value in every one hearing
from us and then realizing there's
things that we could bring to the table
in terms of giving perspective on these
are here's an anecdote that we heard
from a mythical beast we're gonna share
it with all of you in order to help you
understand the difference that all of
the work that we're doing makes in
people's lives it's even if they some
people knew it here or there is helpful
it's helpful for them to hear it from us
and just to kind of hear and experience
our passion for what we're working on
but also to have a little bit of fun I
mean we I don't know how we started
opening every meeting with people share
so if they if they've had a run-in with
a celebrity like a fight like a lot of
people who work for us they they get in
they get in brawls with celebrities no
they just spot celebrities so I would
call that a run-in I think I think
somebody just told a story at one point
and then yeah now it's how we open every
meeting and it's there's always I mean
when you got a company that size and
you're in Los Angeles without fail
someone has seen a celebrity and it's
almost always a funny interaction or
situation and it's funny
connecting and then we go through an
agenda of you know all the different
areas and what you know milestones and
things that were excited about night it
took a while for us to realize that
there was there was value in that well
it took us a while to realize there was
value in it because we again there's
been a slow transition over the years of
us seeing what we were building at
mythical entertainment as a vehicle to
allow us to do the things that we were
most creatively excited about again we
didn't get in this to be business people
we got in this to be creators but then
once you realize you've got this
business that needs to be led and you
have to be involved sometimes you have
to say okay well I'm actually not going
to be able to just throw myself into
this creative project and just be the
artist guy all the time that can come in
when he wants to and just waits until
he's inspired it's like no you actually
have to provide the structure and the
leadership for a company to be healthy
and so it's a there's a there is there
those are two different things in two
different modes and so a lot of this
just comes down to scheduling for us and
making sure that okay know we've got the
meeting we got to be ready for it
do you think that when we have our
company-wide meeting and is there's the
big board room table and everybody's
around the table and then in the
bleachers behind the table and here we
are both seated next to each other
shoulder to shoulder behind the table
facing them
not unlike we would sit behind the GMM
desk and then there's a there's a
there's like the business banter version
of good mythical morning do you think I
wonder if they feel like it's a bit of a
business show not that it's not that
it's fake or that it's insincere I don't
think they would think that but just
that it's a bit like the business for
sure that is rule I'm sure that is it's
a it's a little unusual for like an
intern who was like been watching the
show and then they come to the first
meeting oh they're just kind of sitting
at a desk like they do all the show I
nearly thought about it but yeah it's
but it's not as entertaining
as the show no for sure no and it
doesn't need to be that's not what it's
about I'd say another aspect of this is
that okay so we're still learning a
bunch of lessons about that about what
it what it means to to try to be
creative and try to lead a company and
we got we have a lot to learn but
because we have kind of sorted out some
of this and learned some of these
lessons and put some of these things in
place and we felt like we had gotten to
a place where it was like there's a nice
balance of having creative freedom but
being able to provide leadership but
also being able to entrust people to
lead teams really efficiently and to
create a great product that made the
decision to acquire Smosh last year
mm-hmm
an easier decision for us again not
something we ever set out to do we never
thought we were going to be acquiring
other internet businesses and if you
even even if you had asked us at the
beginning of the year that we did that
we would have been like no what that's
not something we're interested in it was
serendipitous we told that story about
how everything lined up perfectly but
because we had a culture and we had a
system in place it wasn't that big of a
stretch to incorporate a whole other
team a whole other company into our
company and sort of apply a lot of the
same principles because we had gotten to
a place where we were comfortable with
people who had their own creative vision
in fact that was what we were after
mm-hmm and we just were like but here's
the business structure and the sort of
the production side of things that you
can kind of put in place to make your
content dreams come true but you guys
are the ones that are there gonna have
to be in charge of the creative you know
your fan base you you've got more
subscribers that we do you've you've
been doing this for longer than us and
that was an interesting experiment of
just being able to say all right let's
take the things that we've learned and
apply those lessons to this acquisition
but we've already got creatively
motivated people in place and I think
that that's one of the reasons that it's
worked so well for both both sides and I
think it's hearing feedback from Ian and
from Smosh it it makes me feel good
when they talk about the the contrast
from their experience before to being
under the wings of mythical because it's
they described it as a different
experience being in a creator led
company you know I and I really think it
comes down to
there's definitely business
accountability and there's there's lots
of structure and there's a there are
corporate aspects to what we do now I
mean with this many people there has to
be but there's it's all built on the
foundation of belief that if you're if
you're passionately expressing yourself
in a way that's committed to reaching
your audience and connecting with them
honestly and you've got a proven track
record that that's earned trust so the
creative quotient is a lot higher than
in some companies where it's just okay
we might you know I don't know how other
companies would do it in terms of how
they would calculate and and factor in
creative decisions but there's just a
level of trust and belief there that
subject to parameters and this doesn't
this doesn't just apply to Smosh it
applies to us and we just convey it to
them as well that that's what that's
what leads to success you know you can't
underestimate the creative component and
the passion involved in it yeah and the
sort of the latest aspect of this in
recognizing that you have a culture
embracing that culture and trying to
shape that culture that's been put into
a bit of a test with what's happened
with the coronavirus yeah and you know
we're very much as you can tell by the
fact that we're at home we're obeying
the the social distancing requirements
and no one is working at the office
everybody's working from home and that's
created its own unique challenges from a
technical perspective which we've kind
of overcome but it's been a unique
challenge in terms of
a cultural aspect of the company because
there what is the culture now when
everyone is just at home all day and
communicating via videoconference so I
mean I think one of the one of the
things that we decided to do early on is
like okay well let's have our
company-wide meeting but let's do it as
a big zoom call and everybody's gonna be
on there and it was interestingly or
surprisingly connecting and we got a lot
of feedback from people you know we did
the thing that we always do we started
it off asking people to tell celebrity
spottings stories and there was actually
there was actually one somebody saw Jon
Hamm on a balcony hey you know and it's
like it's a sort of a different flavor
when we're all social distancing but
there was a what we realized is that
having made the decision to set up this
regular touch point where we're
communicating with our company and our
company is communicating with each other
it wasn't a difficult thing to carry
that into this weird time but there
wasn't talking on video it was an added
weight to it just coming to the
realization that this was a leadership
moment where we could communicate what
the plan was and give it give as much as
we could a sense of security that like
okay we are we are moving forward this
is a difficult and trying time but we're
in this together
and so yeah that was okay it's like this
is this is I feel needed as a leader I
feel like this is an opportunity for us
and it's not easy I think when you look
at this scenario or looking back on
everything there was never a point where
we felt fully ready you know I mean
saying that we were kind of blindsided
by the CEO Ness of it all is something
that you just you take every every day
and you take every opportunity for what
it is and we learn from our mistakes and
we we try to learn from everything like
I think these lessons again are still
for for us as we're continuing to learn
and hone the
I don't know I just I I especially in
light of what we're dealing with now I
just have this added perspective of it's
it's a privilege to be able to lead a
company even though I never knew I
wanted to do that and sometimes it's
still very frustrating and it doesn't
seem like the main thing that I want to
be working on I do have this sense that
it's it's not only a weighty obligation
but it's it's it's a privilege to do
that and to shape a culture and a
company that not only cares about what
we're creating but it cares about and we
care about all the people that were
working with and as certainly as I'm as
grateful as I've ever been for everybody
who works for us given what we're going
through right now and I think that's a
that's a good way to wrap it up with one
final lesson and that is we're having to
learn to always be looking for the
lesson that we're currently learning
right a lot of these lessons are things
that you don't see them until you look
back until there's some some perspective
after the fact
but I think that over time you get a
little bit better at being like oh oh
actually there's a lesson happening
right now if I can actually figure out
what it is and anticipate it and learn
it right now then we can begin to apply
it and I think that this crisis and this
change the way that our company's been
forced to adapt we're learning new
lessons I mean the sort of the big thing
that we've been trying to do in more
recent years is figuring out what does
mythical mean beyond just the two of us
right what does it mean in terms of
content what does it mean in terms of
just the company and the leadership and
there's only so much that the two of us
can accomplish as leaders and as
creators but the concept of mythical
thanks to our incredible team and also
into incredible fans who have kind of
bought into what we're doing it's given
us we're learning this lesson that
this is whether we want it to be or not
this is already bigger than us but how
do you sort of manage that wisely and
how do you continue to grow it in a way
that you don't it doesn't lose
what makes mythical mythical and
continues to give us opportunities to
you know we still want to personally
create things that are awesome right
we're not done creating new things it's
not like we're about to walk off into
the sunset and say hey we made this is
what we've made and now we're done like
we still and would probably always will
think this way we still think our best
work is ahead of us but we're also we've
kind of been forced to embrace the fact
that oh this mythical thing is kind of
just happened and it has a lot of
potential let's do this wisely yeah and
I just let's and I don't deliver I think
our our best work now and that we come
to grips with it also includes
prioritizing not only our own health but
the health of our team and that they're
not just employees but they're people
and that if creating a culture is
something that I mean I am increasingly
passionate about because it's it's a
great opportunity and also to continue
to make things that make a difference
it's not just making this stuff we want
to make but making it in a way that
continues to make a difference in
people's lives and can like you said
continue to learn lessons along the way
from our not only our successes but our
shortcomings so I mean it's it's an
amazing position that we find ourselves
in and I'm very grateful for it very you
got the other lessons I just have a
wreck oh yeah Allah
well I mean just to get very practical I
mean at the top of the year we took all
of our team leaders and we said hey
let's go through a book together that we
can discuss and how we can all be better
leaders and so we recommend that book to
you it's called the making of a manager
by Julie Joe last name spelled Z H
you oh so if you're interested in in
tackling some of those issues about how
to how to inspire the best and as you as
you manage people or manage people who
manage people or your managed by people
the making of a manager is I think it's
very helpful especially for people who
kind of find themselves thrust into a
new position of having to lead which is
something that starts happening as
companies grow you go from everybody
kind of doing their own thing to like oh
now I've got a team yeah it's super
super practical easy read very helpful I
also recommend it yeah okay well thanks
for thanks for coming on this business
journey with us
use hashtag ear biscuits as always to
continue the conversation I'm curious
what stood out to you or how our
conversation has been mirrored in your
own experience or I just gave you food
for thought even outside of the business
world and yeah and also let us know you
know just as a concept of getting into
this kind of thing which has linked kind
of hinted at the beginning it isn't
necessarily for everybody right not
everybody is is directly interested or
involved in this kind of thing but did
you find this information intriguing or
interesting even if you don't have a
business of your own because we could
keep talking about lessons that we're
learning in the future all right
well will speak at you next week you're
fired
just kidding we never actually said that
to anybody to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]